bueno después de un vídeo largo y tal
vez un poco pesado vamos a trabajar en
el problema número 6 que espero que no
nos dé tanta lata y que no nos dé un
vídeo tan largo y el problema número 6
tiene la siguiente figura tenemos tres
rectas déjame dibujarlas aquí tengo una
recta por acá dame otra recta por acá
más o menos así y después tengo una
tercera que también concuerda con este
punto más o menos por acá
ok las tres se intersectan en este punto
las tres se intersectan en este punto de
aquí ok y nos dan los valores de ciertos
ángulos así que vamos a ponerlos de una
vez este ángulo vale x este ángulo vale
james este vale z este vale z
este de acá r r
ese y este este este de aquí este y el
problema dice lo siguiente tres rectas
se intersectan en un mismo punto
en este punto de aquí como se muestra en
la figura siguiente ok y hasta aquí la
figura cuáles de las medidas de los
siguientes par de ángulos no son
suficientes para determinar la medida de
todos los ángulos cuáles de las medidas
los siguientes par de ángulos es decir
te voy a dar dos ángulos
y si te doy dos ángulos cuáles de estos
dos ángulos no son suficientes para
determinar todos los demás ángulos
vamos a ver los incisos el inciso am el
inciso a mí me dice te e iceta de iceta
y creo que ya voy entendiendo ok ok
fíjate bien en el inciso am vamos a ver
con calma que me está diciendo me dice
si yo te doy el ángulo t te doy este de
aquí este y te doy además el ángulo z
este de aquí no hay forma de que tú
puedas determinar todos los demás
ángulos 72 solamente esta información y
veamos yo sé que te debe de ser igual a
z porque están en estas dos rectas de
yemen ponerlas de otro color si me fijo
en esta recta de aquí en esta recta de
aquí y me fijo en esta recta de acá en
esta recta acá tengo dos rectas que se
intersectan en un punto y por lo tanto
estos dos ángulos son opuestos lo que
quiere decir que el valor de t
déjeme cambiar el valor de t es lo mismo
que el valor de z ok
una vez que obtenemos que t es igual a z
qué otra cosa podemos saber bueno pues
no tenemos el valor de s ni el de x ni
el de y él
r es decir que no podremos sacar todos
los demás ángulos porque no están dando
el mismo dato el mismo valor de t y dz
entonces creo que la respuesta correcta
es am
vamos a ver si me puedo explicar mejor
si te doy otro par de ángulos supongamos
que te doy t it s t y s te doy t
este de aquí y además te doy es te doy
este acá si te estuviera dando estos 2
bueno pues de una forma muy fácil
podríamos sacar a equis porque están
sobre una misma recta entonces podríamos
sacar a equis si nosotros nos damos
cuenta que es más temas x deberían de
dar 180 entonces es una forma muy fácil
podríamos sacar a equis y una vez que
obtenemos x pues ya sabemos que r debe
de valer lo mismo porque son ángulos
opuestos y ese debe de valer lo mismo
que porque son ángulos opuestos y te
debe de valer lo mismo que z y entonces
yo tendríamos el valor de todos los
ángulos si te doy el ángulo ese y te doy
el ángulo t
sin embargo si te doy el ángulo t y el
mundo z
podemos proseguir daríamos vueltas en
círculos porque solamente podremos saber
que te es igual a z y no podríamos sacar
todos los demás muchas veces los
problemas del s a test están hechos para
que se resuelvan de una manera muy
sencilla y muchas veces la solución de
los problemas está en los primeros
incisos de las respuestas por ejemplo
aquí estaba en el primer inciso para que
no pierdas tiempo en pensar en todos los
demás sencillos y ver si son factibles o
no en este caso como forzosamente
necesitábamos fijarnos en cada uno de
los incisos la solución es el primer
inciso si te doy el ángulo t y te doy el
ángulo z no podemos sacar todos los
demás ángulos porque te estarían dando
el mismo dato y necesitamos al menos dos
datos distintos así que ya está es el
inciso am y vamos a hacer el problema
número 7 borremos esto y vamos a hacer
el problema número 7 que dice
la suma de dos números que difieren por
uno este que te parece si les ponemos
nombre la suma de dos números ok
voy a suponer que estos números se
llaman x bien x + james esto es igual a
t pero no son cualquier par de números
son unos números muy especiales porque
la diferencia de ellos es 1 es decir que
si nosotros sabemos o vamos a suponer
que x es el más grande de los dos x es
el más grandote de los dos es decir x es
más grande que yo entonces la diferencia
entre xy james x - james esto va a ser
igual a 1 porque es lo que me dice el
problema la suma de dos números que
difieren por uno este es decir que si me
tomo la diferencia de estos dos y x es
el más grande la diferencia debe de ser
uno que me preguntan en términos de t en
términos de t cuál es el valor del
número mayor
ok perfecto pero el número mayor de
estos dos es x entonces lo que queremos
sacar es x 2 en esta ecuación de abajo
que por cierto la voy a poner
justo aquí para que podamos utilizar un
sistema de ecuaciones es decir mi primer
adecuaciones x + y esto es igual a tm y
mi segunda ecuación es que x menos esto
es igual a 1 y yo lo que quiero obtener
esa x pero como función de t ok pues qué
te parece si sumamos estas dos
ecuaciones xx me va a dar 2 x 10 - éste
y éste se cancelan y me queda que 2x es
igual a t 1 t más 1 perfecto ya estoy
casi al lado de la solución porque si de
aquí despejó a x voy a obtener que x es
igual a temas 1 a temas 1
entre 2 y estoy dándote el valor de x en
términos de t
es decir x como función de tema que por
cierto esta es la respuesta c el inciso
que tiene esta respuesta es el inciso
sem y ya está
esta es la solución del problema número
7 dos números cuya suma stem y cuyas
diferencias 1 nos dan dos ecuaciones que
cuando nosotros las resolvemos para el
número mayor que el número mayor era x
es justo lo que dice aquí entonces
obtenemos que x es igual a temas 1 / 2
perfecto vamos a resolver el problema
número 8 y creo que vamos bastante bien
en tiempo problema número 8 y dice lo
siguiente el número de hermanos por
estudiante en una clase de preescolar
nos da la siguiente tabla vamos a un
grupo de preescolar a un salón de clases
le preguntamos a cada uno de los niños
cuántos hermanos tiene y nos dan la
siguiente tabla entonces déjame ponerle
aquí aquí tengo esta tabla
y voy a hacer algo más o menos como por
aquí ok y dice que aquí tenemos el
número de hermanos aquí está el número
de hermanos número de hermanos
manos y aquí dice la cantidad de niños
la cantidad de niños que tienen este
número de hermanos la cantidad de
estudiantes de estudiantes ok y primero
me dicen que cero hermanos cero hermanos
tienen a tres estudiantes es decir que
hay tres estudiantes que tienen cero
hermanos ok
después me dice que uno uno va a dar a
seis es decir que seis niños seis
estudiantes tienen solamente un
hermanito un hermano okey después me
dice que dos va a dar a 22 estudiantes
tienen dos hermanos y por último tres me
va a dar a uno solamente un estudiante
tiene tres hermanos ok vamos bien hasta
aquí días después de hacer esta tabla
ingresa un nuevo estudiante y se observa
que el promedio de los hermanos por
estudiante en el salón es exactamente
igual a la mediana de hermanos por
estudiante
del mismo salón wow esto está
sorprendente a ver me sorprende tanto
que esté no sé por dónde atacar lo vamos
a leer la otra vez
días después de hacer esta tabla ingresa
un nuevo estudiante y este nuevo
estudiante tiene x hermanos vamos a
suponer entonces el nuevo estudiante lo
voy a poner aquí
nuevo nuevo estudiante estudiante
tiene tiene
x hermanos x hermanos ok perfecto
no sé cuántos hermanos tienen pero
ingresa a este nuevo estudiante en lo
que nos dice es que en ese momento la
mediana se vuelve exactamente igual que
el promedio de los hermanos por
estudiante en el salón la mediana déjame
ponerlo aquí la mediana con un color más
llamativo la mediana
se vuelve exactamente igual que el
promedio que el promedio
de los hermanos por estudiante en el
salón ok después de que ingrese a este
nuevo chavo
se dan cuenta que la mediana es igual al
promedio es lo que nos preguntan
precisamente es cuántos hermanos tiene
el nuevo estudiante es decir cuánto vale
x wow esto está increíble
a ver veamos por dónde puedo empezar yo
sé primero pensemos qué es lo que pasa
antes de que ingrese este nuevo
estudiante antes de que ingreses nuevo
estudiante qué es lo que pasaba con la
mediana y cuando el promedio primera
fijemos la mediana en la mediana
ya no vamos a ordenar los datos de menor
a mayor y fijarnos cuál es el dato que
está justo en medio entonces tengo tres
estudiantes que tienen cero hermanos
tengo cero hermanos cero hermanos cero
hermanos ok después tengo seis
estudiantes con un hermano déjenme
cambiar de color tengo seis estudiantes
con un hermano uno dos y tres
4 5 y 6 perfecto después tengo dos
estudiantes con dos hermanos dos y dos y
por último tengo solamente un estudiante
con tres hermanos un estudiante con tres
hermanos ok vamos a ver cuál es la
mediana de estos datos la mediana de
estos datos es tengo 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 11 tengo 12 datos 12 datos y la
mediana es el valor que está justo en
medio así que veamos 1 2 3 4 5 6 la
mediana en este caso es 1 ok y después
ingresa un alumno con equis cantidad de
hermanos con equis cantidad de hermanos
pero x puede ser 0 1 2 o 3 así que
veamos si fuera 0 vamos a ponerlo aquí
si fuera 0 entonces aquí de hecho lo voy
a poner con color blanco pongámoslo con
color blanco si fuera 0 cuál sería la
mediana de estos am ahora son 13 datos
la mediana de estos 13
seguiría siendo uno porque tengo 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 la mediana sería este de aquí que
es uno bueno es un dado caso de que este
nuevo estudiante tuviera cero hermanos
pero qué pasa si tuviera un hermano a
ver si tuviera un hermano y lo voy a
poner por aquí tiene un hermano sigue
siendo de color blanco y entonces dónde
llego al número 7 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
sigo teniendo a la mediana justo aquí ok
esto en el dado caso de que tuviera una
hermana entonces si tienes hermanos
déjame ponerlo aquí con cero en manos
cero hermanos hermanos
la mediana se mantiene entonces la
mediana se hace
si tengo un hermano un hermano hermano
ok la mediana sigue siendo uno que va a
pasar ahora si tengo dos hermanos para
esto déjenme borrar esto de aquí y voy a
borrar este de aquí y voy a ver qué es
lo que pasa cuando tengo dos hermanos
cuando el nuevo estudiante tiene dos
hermanos y si tuviera dos hermanos
estaría justo aquí entonces vamos a
ponerlo a tienen dos hermanos mi nuevo
estudiante está justo aquí y vamos a ver
cuál es la mediana tengo que contar 7 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 llegó al valor de 1 otra vez
si tengo dos hermanos dos hermanos
hermanos
vuelvo a obtener que la mediana es 1 es
decir que la mediana se mantiene
constante y que me pasa si tengo tres
hermanos
déjame borrar otra vez todo esto de aquí
volvemos esto este
ok y ahora voy a suponer que tengo tres
hermanos si tengo tres hermanos entonces
qué pasa con la mediana pues la cantidad
de hermanos de este nuevo estudiante
estaría justo aquí y si contamos siete
sería uno dos tres cuatro cinco seis
siete vuelvo a caer en este valor si
tengo tres hermanos en el dado caso de
que tenga tres hermanos hermanos
la mediana sigue siendo 1 es decir que
en todos los casos la mediana sigue
siendo uno puede ser que tenga cero
hermanos un hermano dos hermanos o tres
hermanos la mediana se mantiene
constante es uno esa no cambia ok
entonces ya vimos qué pasa con la
mediana la mediana tiene que ser 1 ahora
qué pasa con el promedio pues vamos a
caer el promedio de estos datos para
esto déjame quitar a este dato de aquí
para que no nos confundamos este dato de
aquí lo voy a quitar ok no me sirve por
ahorita quitemos lo muy bien y ahora voy
a pensar qué es lo que pasa con el
promedio si yo tengo estos datos cuál es
el promedio pues vamos a sumarlos me
quedaría 0 + 0 + 0
más 111 más
uno más uno más uno más uno más uno uno
dos tres cuatro cinco más uno ya esto le
tengo que sumar más dos más dos más dos
más dos y esto yo tengo que sumar 3
3 ok y a todo esto le voy a sumar la
cantidad de hermanos que tiene el nuevo
estudiante es decir más x ok todo esto
lo tenemos que dividir entre la cantidad
de alumnos que hay y tengo dos
estudiantes más uno nuevo son 13 ok esto
es igual a 13 y cuánto me da esto de
aquí pues es 0000 aquí tengo 66 más
cuatros 10 10 más 3 13 me quedaría 13
más x 13 más x entre 13 esto es el
promedio que tengo ya contando el número
de hermanos que tiene el nuevo
estudiante pero yo sé que el promedio
tiene que ser igual a la mediana y está
de lujo porque ya casi acabó esto de
aquí tiene que ser igual a la mediana
que vale 1 por lo tanto no me queda de
otra
tiene que pasar que 13 más x entre 13
sea igual a 1 o dicho de otra manera 13
más x sea igual a 3
o dicho otra manera x tiene que ser
igual a 0 para que se cumpla esta
ecuación x tiene que ser igual a 0 es la
solución de este problema en el dado
caso de que se cumpla que el promedio y
la mediana sean iguales entonces este
nuevo estudiante no debe de tener
hermanos debe de tener cero hermanos
cero hermanos y ya está aquí está la
solución de este problema este vídeo
está durando mucho ya no tengo tiempo y
además se ha soltado la lluvia por acá
así que voy a refugiarme de la lluvia y
espero que se haya entendido nos vemos
en el siguiente vídeo